well this is not a very good sign for
the Biden campaign liberals who scooped
up Dr fouchy and Ruth Bader Ginsburg
bobbleheads they are not rushing to buy
Biden and kamla memorabilia souvenir
store owners say folks just aren't into
the current crop of Democratic party
Heroes the founder of the progressive
T-shirt maker putting it this way quote
we produce kamla haris stuff which
doesn't sell at all and it's not just
the poor sales of Swag the White House
is having trouble selling their economic
message the term bomic is nowhere to be
found in the president's recent speeches
despite saying it was the word of the
year just a month ago I don't think the
me it as a compl orally started
referring to my Economic Policy as
biomics well guess what it's working
biomics is just another way of saying
restore the American dream the plan is
working bomic right kind of flows off
the tongue here to talk with you about B
nomics which is the word of the day word
of the week word of the month word of
the Year here at the White House Biden's
Hometown reveals how it really feels
about
biomics it's just gotten tougher I feel
like for everybody oh how could he be
seeing it through our eyes if you know
it's just gotten tougher it's gotten
worse I'm a registered Democrat but I'm
not happy this economy
sucks I mean everything's going up
except you know
paychecks Greg have you purchased any
bobbleheads it's it's hard to make a
bobblehead when somebody's already a
bobblehead right it's kind of redundant
you're not going to get a kamla Harris
bobblehead made they should have got it
like a coffee table book of V diagrams
or a kamla Harris you know public
speaking for idiots that would work all
successful phenomenons are are organic I
mean this is why let's go Brandon took
off nobody planned that but dark Brandon
do you remember that that's where Biden
put on sunglasses it was like Grandpa
taking up skateboarding you know it just
it doesn't work it looks completely fake
but everything the Dems do these these
days is orchestrated right now it's like
somebody just put out the bat signal to
tell the media government and the Tech
Industries it's time to not naify Trump
and and it's time to like say he's going
to cause World War I you had the
Atlantic do like 25 articles just about
him you have Liz Cheney having these
meltdowns that he's going to cause World
War III and the purpose of this bat
signal and getting everybody the whole
cabal together is to make every action
afterwards permissible it's like if
you're trying to stop Hitler then
everything is on the table and that's
this is why next year is going to be
really weird because they're preparing
they're setting it up so they're going
to be able to just completely demonize
millions of people Jesse we have said
before that Biden what he calls
accomplishments we actually sometimes
see as vulnerabilities and the economy
is one of them and when they decided to
take bonics uh by the horns and try to
make it like Obamacare it was sure to
backfire I don't know if you read
Breitbart this morning Dana I did not I
missed it what happened got to read
Breitbart every morning so you remember
home alone when mcau caulin goes grocery
store shopping and he has his lists so
in 1990 he buys milk bread toilet paper
laundry detergent fabric softener cling
wrap macaroni and cheese a turkey TV
dinner OJ and a bag of plastic army men
cost
$20 last year he used a coupon he used a
coup oh maybe even less last year or
whatever when
$44 this year the same exact grocery
list
$72 where are you shopping Kroger breit
bar chops at Kroger according to this
article so you can't get out there and
say things are good when they're not
they're doubling in prices when I was at
the Christmas tree farm buying my tree
they have all these ornaments what did I
see not a single KL or Joe I saw fouchy
and I saw rbj Still Still and there was
only a couple left that means they're
still hot when Trump was President
people would send me these Trump pens
you click it and he's like build a wall
remember Obama he put his face on
everything I thought it was kind of
tacky but again when you have a
passionate relationship with the
candidate you we like Ike this stuff
they were selling Reagan Bush
sweatshirts like 10 years ago thing was
flying off the shelves you can't sell it
I'm beginning to think maybe they're
right maybe he's not really president or
they should just Target the right
products or maybe he's not really the
real president I think that's we Jessica
you did have a lot of Democrats now
coming out and saying yeah we're not
going to use the term biomics anymore
because they realize it's actually
hurting them and that's their
prerogative every race is local you do
whatever is best for you some people
want to campaign with him some people
don't but know Jesse and I have
discussed this many times bobbleheads
don't equal votes people showing up at
rallies don't necessarily equal votes
this happened in the 2015 2016 primary
Bernie Sanders Hillary Clinton but
Bernie's packing the stadiums how is it
possible well Hillary Clinton's a real
Democrat so she was our nominee 2020 Joe
sitting in the basement Trump's pack in
the rallies he loses by 8 million votes
merch is down generally and the GOP is a
complete failure when it comes to
fundraising there that article that came
out in early November about Ron McDaniel
and she has the lowest amount of cash on
hand at the RNC since 2015 Democrats
have doubled it Joe Biden Q3 71 million
Donald Trump the icon right mug shot
t-shirt everyone wants 45 million and
he'll probably spend it on his legal I
have seen more Trump mug shot t-shirts
in three months than Biden merch in
three years all in his closet where do I
hang out I hang out in America judge um
you certainly do not hang out in any
spot of America that I have I hang out
here I haven't seen it here buing I
haven't seen in Manhattan a single Joe
Biden t-shirt judge Janine okay I can
tell you this that Donald Trump has made
a fortune off of that mug shot okay an
absolute Fortune his book is selling
like crazy people love the mega hats the
mega shirts the mega coffee mugs the
Mega Flags go to Florida vot to Florida
and why is he beating Joe Biden right
now it's ridiculous not you can go right
yes she is okay look this is my turn to
talk okay so in addition to that the
only thing that my dogs like is I want
you to see this particular thing that my
dogs especially the new one now that's
Joe Biden my dogs fight over that one
all right but the and the truth is
inflation is up it's the highest since
Jimmy Carter grocery prices are up 20%
Energy prices are up I don't want to
tell you what my ConEd bill was
yesterday it's like a mortgage payment
and the hourly earnings fell 3% under
Buy Rose 7% under Trump raise it IIs my
kid there she has it that's all she's
going to say I next nothing to say from
thieves including your Christmas tree
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else